babe right now today i got a live
chrissy chaos podcast in montreal then
tomorrow i am headlining club soda in
montreal friday july 29th and it is an
all-new hour of material if you've seen
me on the road in the last year this is
60 minutes of brand spanking new and
guess what bubbas if you go to
christiecomedy.com
right now not only do we have montreal
today montreal tomorrow we have the brea
improv in august then we have san
francisco in september and chicago in
september and we've added tarrytown okay
tarrytown in west texas terrytown we've
added we've had it milwaukee we've added
uh wiscon madison wisconsin um and we've
added minneapolis minnesota plus more in
the south christiecomedy.com i'm so
excited about my new hour material it's
wild
all right guys here's here's what we're
doing we're not going on the road again
until october but we got tons of cities
and you have tons of time to get good
tickets right now uh october 14th we're
in hamilton ontario okay uh toronto on
october 15th toronto you've been asking
me i'm there then we're going to
richmond virginia we're going to hershey
pennsylvania we're going to knoxville
we're going to atlanta georgia we're
going to the alabama theater in
birmingham alabama we're going to
louisville kentucky we're going to
evansville indiana we are going to
florida by way of jacksonville tampa and
orlando and then of course in california
we have dates at sacramento santa rosa
and san jose everything is on sale right
now at
savilecanocomedy.com
you got a couple of months get some
friends together get some tickets come
have a good time
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey
[Music]
i
wish you hey babe
[Music]
hey babe hey baby my um my daughter's
got me this shirt for father's day nice
daddy nice you got a sticker on it still
be careful right there on the front
there that's what yeah it's a sticker
guys you know
daddy uh you know i just learned well i
didn't just learn but i just read an
article about zaddy's zaddy's tell me
what you know tell me what you know
about zaddy's okay so if i had to guess
yeah what i think a zaddy is yeah is um
is uh like a young but of age hot guy
okay over 20 like a 20 let's say a 22
year old fox
opposite
silver fox uh so with zaddy's an old guy
yes
what age determines zaddy
i think 40s and up like that so i'm
three
almost i'm two issue i'll be i'll be 38
in a month
right i'm almost zaddy material you you
could be a zaddy depend i'm sure you're
on the cusp of zadiness i'm on the cusp
is adding this
i i guess you're falls out of me if i
was considered
i've been considering it for years now
ryan reynolds it's saying here is a
zaddy
okay
daddy is an attractive
older man as zaddy is a man with swag
who was attractive and also fashionable
it appears that it has less to do with
age well not according to the article i
just read well full article full well
because they're saying ryan reynolds is
a daddy he's over 40 but then zane malek
of one direction definitely not under 40
is also a zaddy i have news for you uh
miriam webster's dictionary this is off
merriam-webster yeah wait wait i'm sorry
we that that right there that definition
right there is off of miriam webster
indeed yeah
that's what miriam wester miriam webster
they're they're basically
they're running out of words yeah that's
what happened well i read that it's an
older man that's fashionable with a
little bit some swag and then mature so
zaddy differs from dilf
um
i guess they're in this cuff from the
same cloth
okay you know because i'm sure they were
zaddy too is the name of this episode
dil sadie's dilsatti's
yeah
this is the origin of zadie is saying
wow zaddy came out ty dolla sign
released on august 25th my birthday is
august 26th august 25th 2016 as a third
single from his mixtape campaign zadie
so it's from ty dolla sign so why did he
so he made up zaddy though that's what
this is saying but i don't know was
zaddy co-opted then we're going on zaddy
winky here
uh yeah we're on wiki feet
um i think it's yeah i think it's a
music thing
music video was in tokyo in japan i
gotta get to go back one sec i know i
want you really bad too i've always
wanted to go to japan go back one time
to that page
uh just scroll down because it said it
said
a little more
a little more
oh no
up up
no no where the hell will you primp go
up over here no no it was on the wiki
page we'll go we're on wiki feed here
scroll scroll down let's go down scroll
down all right scroll down more it says
like it said something about zaddy
school down more and more and more more
more
in popular culture okay zaddy passed
into slang culture as a term for a good
looking fashionable man with swag okay
no no big dylan all right so i mean do
we want to wait can we invent have we
invented
any type of slang that's going to go
into the zeitgeist
um uh
i mean
allegedly
that um tupperware trouble where you're
throwing peas at me right you're
throwing peas at me
what's up my boy right there um
okay
bottom right dez bishop dez bishop there
you go he's addie that's the article i
write he called him a zaddy wow
dez is getting popular what's up dez
well he is he's always he's very he's
popular he is very popular especially in
ireland
in ireland he is right have you ever
been in ireland yeah i've been there a
couple
times um i um
yeah i would say
christopher maloney 100 zaddy
um yeah who who's passing the zaddy test
for you who's passing his attitude yeah
maloney 100 yeah um oh look at him doing
that split right there
that literally should be the picture
he's doing a full split have you seen
his new ad oh the peloton when he's butt
naked dude he is shredded imagine
peloton pitched you guys that ad wait
he's on the peloton completely naked
you know what they're trying to do
they're trying to opposite they're
trying to course correct that
mr big thing where he died on the
peloton yes and they're trying to put a
hot daddy on look at this butt naked
some people think the way i work out is
strange
honestly i don't get it
[Music]
me i don't think using the peloton app
is strange at all
sure they're famous for their amazing
equipment but the app gets me motivated
to do live for 60 years old man
60 60 cardio no he's not yes he is no no
no he's taking stop it now he's 60 years
old look at how good shape this guy is
how do you know strength training look
at that you okay back there
you okay back up oh my god
they had to go all in you had to go i
even used the app for running
now does that seem strange to you
wow peloton
community
it is a good commercial because it's
like i now every time i think of paluton
i think of a naked christopher maloney i
think of like his straight up crack yeah
i mean he is
ripped can you can you confirm he's 60
because that that would blow my beast
who looked it up
i don't know i don't know if i've seen a
60 year old better shape than him if he
[ __ ] 360
61 years old
oh my god he now i mean that's even next
level zaddy that's like a grand zaddy
yeah that's the grand masters addy grand
masters addie christopher maloney what a
cush job too he's on the same show for
[ __ ] 20 years oh god new york
i mean i am feel terrible about myself
right now oh yeah i feel brutal yeah i
feel you know what you know what you
know what we're gonna look like at 61. i
can't even imagine i'll be alive
yeah
like
like
i
gotta be celebrity men zaddy or not
let's let's
let me tell you pedro pascal
zaddy pedro pascal zaddy no
oh it's internet voting it's not i love
this because it's popular voting it's
not according to the article themselves
so that means now wrote with your heart
not what you think the article 69.7
000 people voted no for pedro pascal
wow i mean 100 percent of zaddy i it
depends on who you ask all right let's
do another one but adam driver i guess
he's i'm saying he's going to be a zaddy
without a doubt like way more than pedro
pascal it depends on who you ask let's
see
oh
whoa he got even worse voting than pedro
pascal
oh so this is stringent
okay so now i understand how we're doing
this christopher maloney couldn't be
more of a yes i mean we just it's
basically we came here for him yeah if
he's not
wow still yo the haterade yeah he's out
on on buzzfeed yeah they're drinking
this all right let's see oscar isaac i
mean i'm not yes god yes
first one first one
special zaddy and he almost has a
hundred thousand views john stamos is
like gotta be no i mean he's hall of
fame he's daddy compared to the old
school he is his daddy but he barely
made it 49 he didn't even make over 50.
only oscar isaac's made over 50. i mean
if he's not a zaddy i don't know who is
that
i'm going to say yes because i like a
funny man i i like him but i'm going to
say no the the people are voting no
remember these are young people on
buzzfeed
wait look at the middle button who
five percent system a hundred and forty
thousand people voted no thanks
this is where we're at by the way right
now ray romano is arguably still one of
the most famous walking comedians on
this earth yeah he he's coming off a
decade of a sitcom that was up there
with seinfeld friends
everybody knows raymond is
top top top and
people don't there's a button that says
who on that oh yeah because that's it
now that's it if you're not from
soundcloud now or wherever you're from
yeah that's it that's it you're done
done
lin-manuel miranda creator of uh
hamilton
let's see i think if the young people
are voting and they know hamilton but i
don't really look at him like a zaddy
for me
please no 58 percent yes uh sure and
please no please no 58
well we're learning that zaddies are
hard to come by skeet all rich is i mean
this is they they don't they don't know
who that is they don't know that's a no
that's that's god that was he was
he got zaddied
thirty nine percent yes thirty nine
percent he he beat the so the way it is
is there's three there's three buckets
and all three buckets comprised a
hundred percent i hope so on this list
that just pops up
[Laughter]
nev shulman creator of catfish
um i'm gonna say ex um
what does excuse me mean
i think that means like what are you
talking about why are you on this list
yeah
by the way
buzzfeed is making those buttons so
they're actually
perpetrating they're perpetuating that
excuse me like they put that there yeah
they're being they're they're they're
they're really kind of pushing they're
putting the guy on the list and then
they're making a button that that helps
you
undercut the guy yeah but they put him
on the list i'm gonna say yes or no
i'm gonna say no only because and this
is no disrespect i don't like a hairy
guy yeah i want more of a hairless
sphinx cat kind of guy i'm not looking
for
a lot of hair no the only guy i like
with hair is homeless pimp right
yeah that's true that's true you know
you speak true wow look at that storm i
know it's it's raining no 55 but yes 25
these windows are holding up first big
test
oh matthew lillard really well they just
put guys from screaming yeah yeah he has
no middle one honestly
this is funny what the [ __ ] i feel like
people are going to vote for on my knees
just because they want to hit them yeah
yeah let's see what happens i bet you on
my knees
[Laughter]
so there's only two two or three zaddy's
on there
you ever wonder
paul wrote as a zaddy if i've ever seen
one's
no drake's too young isn't he then they
got smash pete davidson or jack harlow
it's interesting paul rudd is is is a
zaddy i hung out with him recently what
a guy
small
right i wouldn't call him small you know
what i'm saying like with paul rudd like
like
nobody is better to play ant-man than
paul rudd
well i know i don't see him as he's not
physically imposing
you
he's not a tall guy he's like no he's
probably like in my heist he's not tall
now i don't mean i don't know if he's my
hype but like he wasn't i wasn't like
wayne and
paul rudd yeah now
i i would say
paul rudd
one of the most captivating smiles in
movies unreal perfect smile i'm and he's
like in his 50s and i think i would i
would sign up for what he's got going on
and ant-man this
was shredded he's just a he's just a you
know what he's as cool and down to earth
as he is handsome that guy paul ryan
something else paul rudd
in um clueless stole the movie
i remember my grandfather my grandfather
used to take me and my cousin your
grandfather was like uh as if
he would take us to movies at the green
acres mall in long island he would take
us there and then fall asleep like he
would have us for the summer while my
our parents worked and he would just
take his moves and fall asleep he took
us to see don't be mend the south
central drinking juice in the hood okay
he took us to see um little giants um he
took us to see clueless and i remember
after he took a simena society uh i
swear oh my god because that one's nuts
because he just didn't yeah you know it
was just a guy he was just like he
didn't know i was like oh we want to see
that i don't even care
he falls in we're gonna be like my bad
fall asleep didn't care and i remember
coming out of the movie clueless and he
was like who was that actor what was his
name the guy and i was like which guy
and he was like the one's brother
brother-in-law or stepbrother i was like
uh i think that's paul rudd he's like i
like i remember him saying he's like i
like that guy and i remember that being
like wow my grandfather was a paul rudd
fan in the late 90s so if you're if
you're listening i know that you are
he's been there yeah he's been on the uh
what was his first big movie clueless
paul ryan i don't think people had heard
of paul wright before cleveland very
well may have been i think that's the
first time he landed
why
who let's who can you name who can you
name from from from clueless paul rudd
oh the guy from scrubs yeah uh alicia
silverstone yeah stacy dash alicia
alicia oh
stacy dan stacy dash
who i've
heard joe some some some stories about
who else
uh
i don't know i haven't seen it since
then was it good you've only seen
clueless like you haven't you don't know
like everything we have the vhs yeah but
i i mean i don't really know what movie
what movie and this this is a comp more
complicated question
it's not you don't have it right on the
tip of your tongue okay and this was you
pip what movie if you had to guess have
you seen the most from start to finish
oh wow how you've seen the most wow and
i'm talking about on airplanes at home
like you've just seen it through and
through the most of any other movie i
think i know mine i i probably have like
my top like what would be ten but if you
have to pick one
now that's down to one okay the reason i
think i could say this is because it's
my favorite movie but then also because
they play it
on christmas 24 hours
so christmas story yes okay but i've
also i'm up there with like
old eddie murphy's because those are the
ones anything when i was like in that
wheelhouse of like you know eight to 12
or 13 14 we had the vhs and we only had
so many right and we used to play them
over and over like coming to america
trading places right anything anything
john hughes uncle buck might be might be
it uncle uncle buck uh
ferris bueller
planes trains
see it's crazy how like these movies are
so iconic to you
and i've seen uncle buck maybe twice
i've never seen planes trains i've never
seen trading places i've seen coming to
america maybe once what it's crazy how
dear this is a crazy thing yeah it's
it's just wild
holy [ __ ] like
i i mean i didn't know you're going to
say that yeah you saw coming to america
maybe once you show you never saw
playing streets in automobiles i've
never seen it i've and i've never seen
trading might be one of my favorites
you've seen a pimp of course those are
all bangers yeah those are classics
these are my favorite movies yeah i've
never i've never seen training places
i don't think i've seen is that the one
with um
richard dan aykroyd and eddie murphy
what's the one with richard pryor where
he's like one he becomes deaf one can
see you're talking to see no evil hear
no evil that's what uh
that's with gene wilder yeah yeah yeah
my actual cousin is an extra in that
movie at the racetrack scene and you see
him that's pretty wild he's like ah
what about you pimp what are your movies
mine would be dirty work uh nor mcdonald
i don't think i've seen that either
maybe a million times i had that on vhs
as well
i was a big vhs guy hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds you still have
them well my family had when i was
little we only had the same like 20. but
then i started collecting movies i
wanted to be like get into movies and
stuff right now i gave them i got it rid
of all of them you don't have any vhs
donated i mean you wish you had them no
you could get letting them go there's
too much
i have like i kept a couple of like old
ones i remember i had the original
teenage mutant ninja turtle movie on vhs
and the vhs was green like the color oh
that's a fun little thing you did the
thing with uh corey feldman
uh wasn't corey feldman in that
didn't he play a turtle
what was he the voice of one maybe he
was the voice who's the boy
um
those are regular-sized men in there no
those were like child ninjas in there
what were they in the original in the
turtle one yeah in the ridge
were they like were they like regular
sized people in there
little people
well well were they were the turtles
full sized
were the turtles full size yeah who was
the who played the actual turtles yeah
they were full-sized they were wait can
you go to like the original
can you go to like the original
by the way watching a document watching
i'm watching a show on netflix called
the movies that made us have you seen
this it is so fascinating a lot of the
movies i just mentioned are in there
i think speaking of that maybe they
aren't so i think the movie that i've
seen the most i genuinely in my heart
believe it's a tie i think it might be a
thousand to a thousand okay is
sure and far skump
okay i've seen forrest gump a handful of
times yeah fellas more yeah okay so
ace venturas i've seen all the ace
venturas many times okay have you seen
those a bunch no liar liar
i mean i've seen those all a couple a
few times i'm sure right but i don't
really remember them too much where do
you guys fall on forrest gump on on the
female character you're like or you hate
her what's her name again jenny yeah
jedi i
i like it i you know i think with
forrest gump you probably couldn't even
make that movie today because the
you know special needs community would
be like you can't like you can't do this
yeah you're not allowed to do that you
know what's so mean to him yeah i know
but it's kind of like a triumphant cool
story of course it is you know codes
he's like remember when he's like codes
we got killed at the goblins all the
time i would just chase somebody with a
bro
he's you know that entire movie i went
to the i went to the square in
charleston in uh savannah georgia where
they filmed like the opening scenes to
that movie i'm like they just
there's a bench was there right well the
bench isn't there that people go and
look for the bench and they're like oh
i'm taking a picture on the forest gump
bench you're like no they're like the
movie studio just brought in the bench
placed it and then got rid of the bench
no [ __ ] yeah it's [ __ ] up okay
um but anyway we were looking at who
played the turtles who played
does that say tom hanks no no i googled
something else
um
this is impossible maybe imdb i thought
uh i thought he was in the corey feldman
it might have been their suits were made
of fiberglass it says that's so is you
know speaking of fiberglass this is a
good segue speaking of fiberglass you
know what else
you know what else has fiberglass in it
cigarettes mental that
um backboards
nba backboards right
and
the bread from subway
has fiberglass in it no it also has more
sugar the bread from subway has more
sugar than i think like a twinkie
what are you talking about because how
could they put fiberglass and bread well
the reason why i looked into it
it's wild the reason why i looked into
all this subway stuff is because subway
pimp we could pull this article up it
says eat fresh
the only freshness you're gonna eat is
in hello fresh right america's number
one meal kit absolutely um
subway
this is a real story yeah subway now is
offering free sandwiches
for life if you get the 12 by 12 inch
subway hero and logo tattooed on your
chest or back
no you can now
no
you're live no
how many people are going to do this
listen to this if you look anyone who
gets a tattoo of a 12 by 12 inch tattoo
of the logo on their certain back will
receive three sandwiches
yeah listen and then a two by two inch
tattoo on the wrist by separate foot
earns some free subs for a month added
three by three inch that to where their
shoulder blade form or calf wearing free
sandwiches for a year
oh my god if i was a homeless person you
would why not oh my i would i would
literally save up enough for a tattoo
yeah go and get the 12 by 12 and then
it's for life you should still life yeah
what are we doing here dude we're going
to solve the homeless problem
if i was a tattoo artist i would give
away free subway sandwich tattoos yeah
to people that are struggling that's a
great idea and you know what else i was
women why don't we raise the money and
have tattoo artists go around new york
and do that seriously that because you
know what i was thinking about i just
thought about this yesterday what if we
went around and and gave and you know
gave them money as well but gave
homeless people better signs like really
funny signs that we wrote like signs
that crush like we mean signs like like
like for example there's a guy with no
legs who rides his wheelchair up and
down by the staten island expressway i
know the guy that guy and he never has a
sign and i wanted to make a sign for him
i was thinking oh it'd be good if i made
a siphon that said something like i
genuinely don't have a leg to stand on
and then like and then like you know and
then like people would be like that's
funny and then give him a dog
you know what i mean you want to punch
up his sign yes
you know and i was thinking that'd be
like a nice thing to give back
like i'm talking about like jokes like
like david tell level just roast
on signs
hey
babe yes did you know no no but you were
telling me yes because you were telling
me yeah that about um what was it called
it was like a cocoa powder bean bean
this is what you got the best sleeps
truthfully you told me the best sleep
you've had since you've been an infant
yes yeah that's real literally i take it
it's delicious i take it before bed and
i get a full night's sleep i feel like
you're back in your mama's womb right
back in my mama's womb beam
organics
by the way if you're watching and i
think you are we you should take that as
your tagline yeah beam organics be like
right back in your mama's womb that's
what it is beyond the beam team yeah oh
that's good too beam
dream which is the world's most
innovative functional wellness brand
with unique products for everything from
sleep to recovery the dream powder which
tastes like hot it's hot cocoa it's
their best-selling healthy hot cocoa you
told me the taste of it babe it contains
natural sleep promoting premium
ingredients triple lab tested baby so
they went to the lab once and then
someone's like we should double just for
safety and they did it twice and then
somebody was like you know what
all bets are off we're doing a triple
lab test 4-3 no thc and you wake up
refreshed 98 of people surveyed fell
asleep faster when taking bean dream and
99 of people experience better sweep
sleep quality let me tell you something
babe you're in that 98 98 i am and i
just mix it with a little bit of i
personally like to mix it with a little
bit of oat milk you don't have to though
you don't you do whatever you want you
can just drink it with hot water you
take it right before bed uh
don't love it get your money back
guaranteed so what are you really losing
here nothing find out why forbes and new
york times are talking about beam and
why it's trusted by the world's top
athletes like danica patrick and baker
mayfield and sav volcano for a limited
time get 20 off when you go to
shopbeam.com hey babe and use our code
hey babe at checkout that's
shopbeam.com hey babe and use code
haybay for 20 off i love it so bubbas
yeah shopify cha-ching chicken love that
sound homeless pimp you said chicken
chicken
you said chicken chicken
i mean maybe i did what's your favorite
food
uh besides pizza
[Laughter]
i love that sound it makes me smile yeah
that means another sale on shopify i
love it homeless pimp raves about this
he's the one that runs it all and and
tells us about it this when we started
selling the merch and started doing all
that we use shopify and baby the balls
were blown off if you're an entrepreneur
out there even if you're not but if you
are an entrepreneur you literally get
the resources that you get from all
these big businesses
they used to only big businesses used to
only be able to use this kind of thing
but now everybody starts startups
establish businesses alike can sell
everywhere synchronize all your online
and in-person sales and stay fully
informed scaling your business is now
it's it's it's you have endless
possibilities it's the only scale i want
to step on is the business that i'm
scaling with shopify it's more than a
store shopify grows with you this is
possibility powered by shopify
synchronize your online
and in-person sales using shopify right
now go to shopify.com
hey babe that's all lowercase
shopify.com
hey babe all lowercase for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com hey babe right now that's
shopify.com
hey babe
you know like like nice car [ __ ] or
something like that where you'd be like
it's instagramable right right right and
then also give them the money well if
you did something but i like the subway
tattoo idea too yeah i mean i mean but
a 12 what is 12 by 12 though that's a
foot that's no dude it's a full foot
long yeah but what 12 by 12
it says
get a tattoo of a 12 by 12
maybe like 12 inches this way 12 inches
this one like a full like what a foot
long is but 12 by 12 is a foot square
how like a foot long is 12 but not by
12.
it is funny to think about who pitched
that in the subway advertising meeting
that was like i know this is going to
sound stupid i know no no i know it's
going to sound dumb but i was thinking
what if
we give people free sandwiches for life
if they get the subway footlong tattooed
in their body
how long have you been working here
this is my 10th year okay what's your
name my name's harold executive vice
president right now
how about being in a subway when someone
walks in and goes like this
and rips their tits out by the way and
then just orders anything i want to know
what the stipulations are on this yeah
if anything the person who gets the foot
long tattoo will receive a one-time
payment of 50 000
worth of gift cards the others will
receive a 372 gift card for the month
and a 400 4
380 for the year so oh
so what's happening is so you can get a
tattoo on your back and then wait a
minute oh but it's in gift cards it's in
gift cards what if you get a tattoo that
ex like goes away in those two-year
tattoos but you've got 50 g's and gift
cards this is like really go away
yeah no i was going to say get the
fading test get this tattoo
and get it light if that's the thing you
can do tell the tattoo artist you're
doing it for the 50 000 payout yeah and
then make sure that he does it in a way
that he knows already how he's going to
cut or she is going to cover it up
dude how about this are you ready for
this i was driving this was
thursday wednesday or thursday i'm
weren't driving not once again where to
go no i s a lot of people like i there's
no way he'd be driving wednesday
thursday i swear to god since when did
you drive on wednesday
i had covered okay and it changed my
brain a little bit and normally my days
on wednesdays and thursdays are walking
days but i said today i'm gonna drive
okay and i for no reason
took my family loaded up in the car
drove around manhattan my daughters were
like what are we doing like why are we
not in the pool i'm like i need we're
daddy's we're just going to drive a
little bit what does that need what
daddy needed to drive i'm driving i'm
stopped
on bowery
bowery
and houston
okay stopped on bowery in houston which
isn't a cross street wait a second i'm
stopped somewhere on bower no no i think
you're all right i wasn't on bowering
household i was on bowery do you know
where
the building is that was abandoned for
like one guy lived in it it was like on
the newspapers and he turned it into
like an art studio no okay so it's it's
a build it's a famous building you've
seen it there before it's all graffitied
up it's like it's right on about the
corner of bowery and something okay and
i was driving back and i was about to
make a right to go over the manhattan
bridge
and out of nowhere out of nowhere and i
got my family as i went and says out of
nowhere crossing the street with the
skateboard and his friends is jaden
smith no
and i yelled at him i go yo jayden
i was like i know sally's got tattoos
you on his body and jaina goes tell him
i said what up and then
literally hits a perfect [ __ ] wheelie
on the skateboard and drives away and
does one of those you know things where
he flips yeah yeah and just keeps going
like in stride like it was nothing like
it was nothing wow and i was like wow
did you really say that i swear to god
we we used to text but i haven't had a
text from in a while i wonder if she'll
be like hey
one thing i don't notice about jane and
smith and my whole family agreed
his teeth
like it's almost like god is his dentist
yeah the most perfect teeth you've ever
seen in your life jesus christ jesus did
yes jesus said christ cds white
straight
straight and white like us
like us yeah
and i couldn't believe how perfect to
see those he was walking around first of
all the kid looks you you you caught his
teeth in a moving vehicle in a moving
vehicle okay for and he's first of all
he's walking around no shirt on and
jeans like you do ripped yeah ripped no
shirt on though no shirt on see i can't
do it when we only live your life like
that i can't like like he's also
insanely famous so he's gonna get
photographed he's going to get stopped
he's going to get recognized he don't
care that his flesh is out yeah he
doesn't care at all
um
i was i went to the beach this weekend
which i'm not a beach guy but i went to
the beach and you threw me a little bit
you didn't even know my beast
is when do you go to the beach dude i if
you want to i'm going to start sharing
my location with you so you know i'm not
lying when i tell you okay i went to the
beach in manisquan okay which by the way
uh it is interesting to me that places
like new jersey and the jersey shore
continue to keep the native american
names of the towns when the native
american spirits are rolling over in
their teepees right now with what you've
done to their cities right they don't
care that you know that they're people
are eating corn dogs right you know
getting chlamydia that's not change the
name you don't have to call it mana
squan right anymore you don't have to do
that at all but
i was there in maniswan on the beach and
a couple of people came up to me and
recognized me and i was of course
shirtless on the beach and a couple of
people came up to me and recognized and
my immediate response like immediate
reaction somebody's like oh hey chris
what's up let's see your pot i went like
this
[Laughter]
i
[Laughter]
i did it multiple times and the people
we were with were with our neighbors
like why do you do that every time like
ah it's just like a reflex and the guy
one of the guys i was with was like yeah
like you don't you're like your body
doesn't look bad or anything i was like
it's just a reflex and i just like hey
what's up
i'm here with my family guys
so uh i can't do any pics they're like
we don't want it to we don't have our
phones we're on the beach i can't do any
pecs i mean picks
um i can't do any pictures
like that that's the name instead of
instead of uh whatever we said first
maybe we call it pack shirts pictures
well let me ask you a question you told
me you went down to the jersey shore and
you said you went with a neighbor and i
called you mr staten island now call me
mr steiner so you you are that you got
that in where you commit to spending a a
seaside day
with with your neighbor they have
children too they got children their
children one of their daughters goes to
school well both their daughters once
just graduated goes to school with my
daughter mm-hmm so we they take the bus
together and you hit it off with these
people hit it off and normal people
completely normal people born and bred
staten islanders okay you know and you
you have stuff to talk about with them
are they constantly asking you about
your
career because i'm assuming that's the
interesting
that's that would pique people's
interest that you're a
comedian and an entertainer you know
what believe it or not believe it or not
they don't i'm walking on air never
thought i could feel so free
flying away on a wing and a prayer
who could it be
believe it or not
i like it
um go ahead believe it or not so believe
it or not so do you know that show
but you didn't see trading places
well believe it or not it's just an
american 40-year-old virgin oh that
that's the song from the 40-year-old
version oh you don't know from the
greatest american hero
is that what it is
that was a theme song to a show about a
superhero uh in the 80s uh it was like
an hour long i believe
like comedy drama
uh or comedy i suppose action whatever
you know about a superhero didn't know
how to how to be a superhero what
dramedies drama comedy drama comedy but
those are called dramatics but i don't
know when dramedy's was coined it was a
crammer it was like a crime comedy yeah
yeah uh there he is i
oh there you go and he would crash he
didn't know how to fly
it's pretty funny yeah yeah yeah
um
is that regis philbin all right no it
looks like um
so i talked to these neighbors about a
lot of they almost never talked to me
almost exclusively never the only thing
they said was we went down to a
restaurant and a couple of people were
saying hello you know whatever and was
fine no problem and the only thing they
said was like
you know
the father was great like smart guy he
was like i can't imagine that's fun
and i was like well it's not that it's
not fun i said i appreciate recognition
because you know there's plenty of my
peers that i started with that don't get
this and i understand it's like uh you
know it's it's nice to know that your
sign is successful people have seen my
work it's nice i said oh don't let it
get to my head i know that it's fleeting
and meaningless but i said you know it's
nice he goes no no i he goes it's a
beautiful thing but he was like i just i
can't imagine it's fun yeah and i was
like it kind of made me sit like
existentially like i sat with that a
little bit i was like yeah is it not
yeah
he was like because he said to me
i've never thought about this right he
was like i just feel we were eating
dinner like he wasn't attacked he was
just like it's just a regular guy and we
were just drinking wine eating dinner
and he was like i just it just feels
like he goes i wouldn't want like
everybody to know what i'm doing all the
time he goes i kind of feel like nice
that he was like i no matter what i do
or don't do nobody cares
it's a very freeing feeling it is he was
like i just have to re he said something
crazy he goes i kind of just only have
to answer to my wife and daughters he
goes where you have to answer to your
family your girl your daughters plus
these strangers who have no idea who you
are you have to answer to that wow and
and they they they feel
you have a responsibility to so many
strangers he goes that has to be
exhausting and i literally was like do
you have a gun
i'll kill myself right now i know yeah
wow he's very perceptive well that's why
i like him he he comes at more like that
he's a very very smart man what does he
do
i think he works in like ad stuff like
he's a male prostitute yeah yeah he um
yeah
he actually has a job where he's like
it's boring but you know they do very
well their house is like a palace okay
so so you so you can feel yourself
around them it wasn't like you felt like
oh my god you know fully myself like
they don't uh and they're very like
accommodating too they're like you know
like anybody but like whatever like yeah
like it's been hard for me to meet
outside of our friends and our scope of
people and this and that it's
organically hard for me to meet someone
who ca who will just be like that who
won't be like have a million questions
or always be like in the back of their
minds thinking or asking or see i think
the thing with with jokers is i think
that not the problem but the reason is
because you guys go on
tv
and are so approachable on the show and
it's really like your friendship on
display
and you're doing that in in the show
like going up to stranger strangers
coming up to you and it's all fun they
think when they see you that's they
don't they like the the average fan
forgets like you know that was just a
show like that's my job i did that for
eight hours six months ago yeah like now
i'm just with my family i don't wanna
i'm not pranking anybody yeah yeah i'm
not but it's hard for them like they
wouldn't do that to like tom hanks
because tom hanks doesn't tom hanks is
like no dude like removed they're like
tom hanks i don't want to go he has aids
he's from philadelphia right right so so
they're like we got to respect his i
don't want to get closer to him it's
covered because he has hiv or actually
it does have aids right um and he's had
it since 1992. who do you guys think has
the worst job in new york the worst job
in new york in new york
like in television no no just in life
who has the worst job that's what i
think about when i go around new york
who has the worst job you know who's got
a you know who's got a horrific job
i would say
the guy especially now parking meter
beats park and meter maids get screened
up but the guy who has to clean out
these subway bathrooms
that is a who is that like that's a guy
or a girl or a baby there's like a
city-wide uh
that's an mta job you have to clean out
the urinals and the toilets
in the subway is there bathrooms in the
subway some some stations have it i
don't think i've ever been in one in my
life uh most people have disgusting wow
that's a horrible job
also
i mean with the heat wave that's been
going on i gotta think like
some type of like parking garage like a
parking lot yeah that's not good that's
not good that's not good yeah all day
underground and that with that like we
get like the cars exhaust yeah and
people waiting and running back and
forth and having to imagine having a you
know when you like park in a tight spot
it takes a minute but then you get out
you're like all right i'm a little
worried about the car but it took a
while that was annoying and imagine
doing that 1000 times a day every day
that is your job yeah yeah that no i
don't want to do that and then you put a
car somewhere and then you immediately
have to move it to get another car to
get another car right like oh god that
sounds like like it would be maddening
yeah i don't um i don't want to do that
job but again going back to but that guy
is free
that guy is nobody cares about what that
guy is saying or doing on a daily basis
other than his immediate family and
friends that when you said that it was
like oh my gosh no when he said i swear
to god when he said that to me i uh a
tear fell
i was like
because you give it up you don't realize
you give it up i mean you do realize
that but you don't always put it in
perspective and a lot of times people
don't really know our experience or
really care either yeah because they're
like well you're famous or you're this
or that so that comes with a territory
it does but we're still human beings
yeah it's still like it's still like you
know when you sign on to social media
and somebody's saying something negative
to you you're like i don't this is
painful i don't i don't want to see that
or hear that that's insane you know but
i had the worst people at my vancouver
show this week
on canada yeah yeah
i actually loved vancouver i was there
like a year ago i went back and i
thought that it was going to be a great
show
america's number one
kid
hello
that are sure to become everyone's new
favorites like old bay shrimp and
sausage boil and family style grilled
steak lettuce straps are you can't
choose from 55.
more than 55 weekly options between
pre-portion
featuring pre-portioned high-quality
ingredients uh picked at their peak
ripeness hellofresh delivers fresh
quality produce from the farm to your
door in less than a week you can savor
summer flavors right from home are you
kidding me
customize your favorite dishes with
hello custom by swapping out one protein
or size for another hellofresh is 72
percent cheaper than dining at a
restaurant and even cheaper than grocery
i shopping it all the time i use it for
quick meals 20 minutes 30 minutes i come
home the ingredients are all there i
learned to cook with it it's the best
right now go to hellofresh.com hey babe
16 and use the code hey babe 16 for 60
free meals across seven boxes and three
free gifts let me say that one more time
go to hellofresh.com hey babe 16 and use
the code hey vape 16 for 60 free meals
across seven bucks and three free gifts
are you
number one language learning app okay
they make it fun it's not just lessons
either they have all sorts of stuff like
podcasts yeah they make they have 14
different languages and they're done by
actual real linguists none of this ai
artificial intelligence bs
people language learning expert 10
minutes to complete a lesson 10 minutes
okay
that's right learn that on babble 20 a
day money back guarantee uh there's so
many ways so like i said it's not just
the it's not just you download the app
but it's not just the lessons they have
podcast games videos stories and even
live classes now whatever you want to do
and right now you can save up to 60 off
your subscription when all you got to do
all you got to do is right now is you
got to go to babel that's b a b b e dot
com slash hey babe that's
b-a-b-b-e-l dot com slash hey babe for
up to sixty percent off your
subscription that's all you gotta do six
zero six zero okay and you i'm telling
you if you don't look if you don't learn
the new language
on babel with our promo code you're
yeah that's simple on you they're making
this generally on you so if you want to
connect with a relative or you're taking
a vacation overseas or you just want to
be bilingual to impress somebody or just
you know for your own edification uh you
do it and it's babel is language for
life it's language for life so i had
some
oddly had some i had like seven shows
this past week and uh you've had a lot i
know you've been go i haven't seen you
in a month i know it's nice to see you
it's nice to see you um i had to get
everything out of the way but i had some
weird shows like in seattle seattle was
fun right so i get on stage you get
starbucks
i didn't seattle but we did pass the
first original one
there's always too long of a line there
yeah i can't imagine it tastes any
different that's starbucks two blocks
away it does not and there is one two
blocks away yeah i just go to that one
we went so i get i come out on stage and
i literally walk out and i hear a
infant crying
and in vancouver seattle seattle okay
okay this was more fun vancouver is bad
i hear an infant crying so it's look
it's in the fourth row eight month old
baby so i'm like this is wild so i had a
lot of fun with that right so a lot of
fun
places going nuts a lot of the woman
walked out with the baby going on and on
i'm like wow that's [ __ ] booed that's
something was like wow that was
something else so then what was her
reasoning for that by the way well i i i
i mean
i was like you weren't thinking like
when you were [ __ ] you weren't
thinking remember that you had tickets
yeah yeah
like well there's nothing we could do
now we gotta we can't not go to the show
we gotta bring the eight month old baby
yeah it's all fun and then she hits you
with some serious she's like well i
would have she's like but these pr your
prices are too high so now i could hire
a babysitter and then it just brings it
down i was like it's 16 plus suggested
not 16
months um and then and then so i'm like
all right that was really funny that's
how the show opened so then a couple of
minutes later um a guy just walks down
he just walks down the aisle right split
dead center up to the stage and he's
playing music on his phone he's just
holding it up and i'm like i i'm in the
middle of talking i turn and i look i'm
like what are you doing and i the lights
are really like strong on me so i could
barely see him he's like playing music
i was like what do you mean
what are you talking about you've been
saying that he was standing up before i
acknowledged him for like 25 seconds and
he's playing this ringtone that we
created on the show and i'm like oh
finally i heard it i'm like oh yeah
that's the ringtone and he's like yeah
yeah like yeah yeah maybe maybe we'll
talk about that you know you go back to
your seat and we'll deal with that later
that's like i don't understand if you
understand how this works all that kind
of thing so then we're laughing at that
a couple seconds later i'm telling the
story and i go something when i was
running and then i hear someone in the
front go not me
first first row first row just slight of
cinna i go what he goes not me i ain't
running
and i was like okay what yeah and then
he proceeded to pop his leg off and and
hand it to me
literally his leg came up like that so i
was like what because it was like on the
thing and he like twisted it up and it
came up this way so he was sitting in
his chair with his leg going straight up
and he's like i got a leg not me i'm not
running i'm like all right great wait
did he have a fake prosthetic leg yes oh
my god he popped it
dude how funny would it be if he would
have given it to him you took it and
launched it
well something happened close to that
actually
[Laughter]
ah [ __ ] i'm trying to find what an
[ __ ] [ __ ] i have a picture of him in
the front row literally handing me his
leg
and that's got to be the new profile pic
yeah i gotta find it so
so then and then and a few minutes later
a guy in the balcony
screams but not words and not for any
reason he went
and then he didn't say anything
and i was like what i said do we need
security like that guy i think he just
committed suicide yeah yeah
and it was and i was like they just kept
chopping each other like this
and i was like remember the baby
yeah remember in the beginning when we
thought the baby was wild what a psychot
maybe you had like a tourette's section
i do not know what was going on there
but it was pretty fun you know it was
fine but then i went to vancouver they
were
that was like more fun
i drove the whole way beautiful nice on
the coast right yeah yeah oh god shout
out to that to the border agents by the
way because we pulled up and we like
timed it and we're like oh yeah we'll
get to the place a couple hours early or
whatever and there was more traffic than
we do we got to the border there's a
huge line we waited on this line we get
up it's like a toll booth we wait online
we get up there and the guy's like do
you have your arrived can app oh yeah
yeah and i was like well no what do you
mean i said we have everything we have
we filled out this paperwork online i
got these printouts i got my freaking
passport i got my backs i got look
here's no no you need to fill out the
passport canada app and like nobody told
us that he goes well
you can't get through
and we're like well what do we do and
my chris is like can i download it right
now he goes yeah so he downloads it
right now and he goes you have to do it
for all of you so we're like well what
do we do he's like
he's like i cannot give you more than
five minutes if you can't get it done in
five minutes you're gonna have to drive
out go back
go forward back on the line to come back
to the states which was four times the
size of the other line and then get back
on the line to get back to him so it
would have added how long no i would
have missed it would have went to the
night it would have added would have
edited hours right hours so we looked at
him like all right we'll get it done in
five minutes whatever and we're doing it
and it's we could tell it's gonna be
impossible
and uh i was with adam ray yeah and
adam's cracking jokes and everything the
guy like didn't want to hear anything
you know like adam's like oh no problem
man he's like we'll do one he's like you
want me to do one for you like whatever
he said not that and the guy's like now
and then um and then he so he's like
he's like well thank you so much for
letting us do this real quick and the
guy was like i didn't let you do it i
gave you five minutes
so like in other words like in five
minutes your fate is sealed if you can't
do it so chris is in the front end his
hands are like shaking he's trying to
put it he's like what's your email it's
like it's got to do for all of us i'm
like oh my god and we look and the line
to come back
dude it's a half a mile long it would
have took it but you all couldn't just
do a live count on your phones at the
simultaneously he started doing it and
it was like it was a thing yeah so we
said should we all do them individually
he's like he could do them all on that
one so like i just tried to stay the
course it would have canceled the show
and then
one minute two minutes after he goes
i'm gonna give you an exemption and was
like what's that he goes get out of here
just drive through
and we were like
what do we have to show you he's like
nothing he goes just drive through you
didn't even show him any paperwork at
all no we showed him originally we
showed him our passports to start that's
it though no that no nothing no nothing
no nothing after that and then he goes
he goes i don't ever let this happen
again he gives and he gave us a sheet
that said how to get your thing like how
to do it next time and he goes just go
ahead and we're like really
thank you so much because the whole show
had been canceled
then by the way i came back to the
states they didn't have any record i
flew from canada home and when i got
there they wouldn't accept my at global
entry they wouldn't accept it because
they're like you had you come from
canada you didn't get into canada so
that was a whole other to do but my
point was in vancouver they were
horrific
i mean they were so bombed if it's any i
mean because the border agent seemed
great he was so great i told the story
on stage we had a good laugh about it
but then everybody there was you know
there was two couples in the front and
the guys were sitting with each other
and the girls were sitting next to each
other and the girls were
the second i walked out they were wasted
right like chris and adam they were like
there's girls in the front to kind of
waste whatever and they did that thing
where
i had to call them out because any time
i spoke it was like just me and them
were having a conversation they were
like yeah i'm not talking at full volume
i'm saying a joke they're like oh my god
that showcase up and i'm just like hey
guys guys and i had to keep going back i
mean you're not the kind of comic that
like has a crowd like that and you don't
attack people so
in a theater they're coming to see me
it's not really a heckle per se
sometimes they get heckled into theaters
more that's like a club thing but mostly
it's just because people are very very
drunk and they were just drunk and they
kind of don't realize it but they're
probably these self-entitled you know
[ __ ] and they get bombed and then
they just there's no nothing in their
mind that says there's two thousand
other people watching the show let me
shut the [ __ ] up yeah so you know call
them out have a little phone that laugh
move on have to come back again had to
come back and then all of a sudden
another group starts doing it another
group one girl gets up walks to the
stage hands me a phone she goes i want
to show you a picture of me on the price
is right i was like
what do you why are you standing right
now she's like i'm wasting
and and i'm like guys you know and then
the security guard walks up and he
starts like telling us to calm down and
then the guy two rolls back goes ah i'm
like what he goes we're not allowed to
talk to you
i'm like no no i mean we were i was
making jokes about it all but it was it
was a fight oh and then and then then i
start railing on the girl i do start
railing on a while because i'm like you
know whatever i'm like you know
everybody here [ __ ] hates you
everyone's cheering yeah and then
everyone started like and i'm like here
here's the thing all you people that are
drunk and talking right now won't shut
up because you think it's funny i'm like
there's
99 of people want to watch this show so
what i'll do is i'll continue because i
almost said i almost threatened people
in the back and i was like guys do you
want me to continue or not like they
were that drunk and i said all right
i'll continue and then if you're no one
not talking and someone next to you
talks you just punch him in the [ __ ]
face as hard as you can and everyone
everyone just went nuts right and then i
and then i start going on the girl and
then the guy in the front row over here
goes be nice
to me
right so being dead serious serious i'm
ripping on her and he's in the front row
and she's in the front row and he's over
here and i'm like i'm saying stuff to
her i know what i was ripping on her and
then he just goes bed serious a bigger
guy too he goes be nice
and i was like what did you say to me
and he goes i go did you just say be
nice he goes yeah i go are you talking
to me are you talking to her because i'm
talking to you i go you're telling me to
be nice have you been watching the show
for the last 15 minutes i was like she
won't i mean i
start ripping on him i go how dare you
tell me to be nice you know and then he
was like and then she got up walked
across the theater and gave him a hug
did you get it back on the rail zone and
just be able to get it back on the rails
i got it back on the rails i i i mean i
probably like had to cut like three bits
because of all the back and forth i had
to do and then i you know i finished i
ended up finishing strong i didn't think
i was going to i slashed a bit last
second and i was like i'm just gonna get
off at like 50 [ __ ] you know and i
end up going to like i end up doing like
an hour eight or whatever but
it was it was like it was not i hadn't
had a show like that a very very long
time you did what was something like
nine cities in nine days or something
like that right seven yeah seven
cities in nine days
in eight days and you and you know what
i'm most proud of you you did not get
sick did not can you believe thank you
so much thank you so much it was almost
because when i saw it as a bound you've
had it you've had it i've had two or
three people have it right now that
never had it before right now they said
something changed about the covet bug
where the people who are getting it now
the people who've invaded it for two and
a half years yeah somehow that's who's
getting around everyone i know right now
goes it finally got me it finally got me
i know like a handful of people smell
and taste gone you had it gone no it did
it come back right away it's it's back
six is that why you lost a few pounds
because you look good thank you um i i
know well yeah because there's no point
to eat if you can't taste it right let
me tell you something yeah a lot of
people mm-hmm a lot of people said
a lot of people said oh that don't worry
about this we'll never have a female
president they said they'll ever feel
the president but we actually are yeah
because by the nazi copenhagen who knows
kamala could be coming up right so so
and that's what i'm going to canada um
so
this has been hey babe
oh
um so
so remember when trump won and
everyone's like i'm moving to canada
yeah and then nobody nobody moved yeah
people are like no um because it takes a
lot to like you're gonna leave the
country yeah that you're from now
because you don't like the leader shut
up it's an empty threat yeah i didn't
want to i did want to run this by you do
you see what happened to kid cuddy
yeah somebody kept yeah was that show in
vancouver this is just uh miami
yeah oh god play second clip it's so
funny
[Music]
yo
i will walk off this stage
one more [ __ ] thing up here i will
leave i will leave right now throw one
more thing on the stage
[Music]
[ __ ]
you had to know that somebody was going
to throw it after you
now granted listen you he got hit in the
face that's ridiculous i would not have
even
said
actually i give kid cuddy props for even
allowing uh somewhat let me give you a
chance because you get hit in the face
with anything i'm immediately walking
off yeah i'm not doing another second i
mean i'm in the nose look at this
oh
that had to hurt too yeah
i hopefully it was like a plastic but
what actually i saw another video where
the kid right after that another kid
threw it
maybe it was a different angle than the
second throw what is wrong with these so
that second thought is another angle
it's the kid on his own phone being like
yo watch this i'm gonna end this concert
and that one right there and he throws
it and he walks right off and the kid is
like online right now tagged
like it's you know who it is and he said
it's gonna
never
i can't believe you did that because can
you get in trouble what what
pimp have you ever been with all the
music concerts you've been to some like
what happened here if you had to guess
was he bombing what happened here is
that the festival set him up to replace
kanye and they have a public beef
so kanye got taken off well kanye came
on next and then kanye brought out as a
guest they set him up to look like an
ass and then kanye did the song that he
did with cuddy without cutting without
so kanye and cotty do have beef oh yeah
yes about what's the beef i think it's
because of pete
seriously yeah yeah oh because cuddy and
pete are friends yeah
oh god i mean we're grown men here grown
men we're seriously grown men i remember
he told him
don't
he took him off the song because he said
like
don't mess with pete and then i think
he's like what are you talking about
like where he's my friend i agree it's
like you're gonna
who's gonna make somebody choose like
yeah what a stupid it's kind of nutty
speaking of choosing though i do have to
choose between uh cars i gotta get a car
should i right now i have an infiniti uh
qx80 a family car
should i get this it's the jeep cherokee
wagoneer oh i like how i can do you not
cheap cherokee wagoneer jeep grand
wagoneer
a grant a grand wagoneer do i get a
grand wagon i don't know what they look
like now but the old ones like from the
wood paneling are so cool the retro ones
but it's a kids look at that look at
that see that one that says old school
that middle one yeah that is so sick so
if anybody out there is car person go
you know email hey baypod or gmail or
instagram must hey baypod um
tell me if i should get the wagoneer or
the infiniti i have the infiniti qx80
did you it's a family car
i love i love jeeps i love the jeep and
i've been missing the jeep i've been
missing you i've been missing a jeep
wrangler
did you
test drive it i test drove it and i
loved it but the thing is i got three
kids
including a baby so the the infinity is
destroyed the inside because you can't
i'm not gonna not give my kids muffins
and bagels and drinks in the car when we
go you know we're driving a man of squad
it takes two hours like the kids need to
freaking eat the baby needs to [ __ ] so
the interior of the car gets destroyed
now this cheap grand wagoneer is a
little bit more i guess luxurious than
the infinity
and you know i don't know if the kid
like do i get a car like that that the
kids are going to destroy or do i just
get do i just get like a pre-owned
[ __ ] car and just not even spend the
money who cares because the kids are
going to destroy it well you talk about
stains like if you're gonna lease a car
an expensive car and they're gonna mess
it up are you gonna get hit with fees at
the end no it's just like you know like
if you have a personal vehicle no get to
get the nicest car that you like that's
the that pleases you the most you're
gonna be sitting in it and driving it
all the time they're gonna destroy no
matter what car you get so just keep
tabs on that and you can still clean it
and steal the car that you hoped it
would be
i say get the car that that makes you
feel happy when you get inside of it
every day what car makes you feel happy
my car that i have right now i love it
you love that yes pimp does your car
make you feel happy
no i'm very happy to be away from my car
yeah
i'm not a car guy it's just that the car
i have now i absolutely love it
pimp's free pimp's free on pimp's free
on the ferry
he's a fairy guy now
pimp's a nautical guy yeah nautical guy
tim's got a sailor look how great is the
ferry the ferry's great i don't have to
drive anymore you know no traffic the
traffic in new york right now
it's crazy price of the ferry's going up
you're biking it's free no the fast
ferry
i don't i i i don't i don't be [ __ ]
with the regular staten island ferry
where do you take advantage you get the
first very the same terminal as you get
the regular ferry and where do you take
the street where do you take it to
250 vesti street you go to my you do i
just take it sometimes i i've taken the
ferry multiple times as of if i'm on a
cruise to nowhere i just take it get off
do a lap and then come back on the boat
when do you do this i when do you have
the time to take a joy ferry ride
my kids go to camp and then the baby
when we get tt jerry comes over to watch
the baby i have sometimes four hours of
free time and i'll take the phone you're
really mostly working at night at night
yeah i'll do that and you'll drive there
yeah get on that ferry i'll get on that
ferry baby what's that like that ferry
the fast ferry yeah amazing they got a
bar gear coffee beer really food yep
it's clean and comfortable oh clean and
comfortable as a matter of fact see this
is the thing
the ferry is a good kind of thing for
social media too
if you want to clean something up if you
really want to clean something up yeah
charge money for it even a little bit of
money the difference between the
cleanliness of the free staten island
ferry versus the fast free which is two
dollars and 25 cents right is insane
right it's like you're typing into a
ritz it's like you're in buckingham
palace right
right right and then it's like you're in
the sewer on the staten island right
because one's free and one is two
dollars 25 cents if twitter and
instagram was two dollars and 25 cents
the riffraff shout out riffraff love his
latest album would be so
much
better
the riff raff would be gone off social
media yeah riff raff is fun yeah dude i
riff-raff did i ever tell you my story
about riffraff
with riff-raff
[Music]
no are you serious no riff-raff yeah of
course i know riff-raff
[Laughter]
[Music]
don't be afraid don't be ashamed